all right with that let's bring out our
next guest former CIA director former
Congressman former Secretary of State
Mike pompeo's with us
Mr secretary during your time as the
Secretary of State and the CIA director
um did you come across anything that
you'd be able to tell us as it relates
to alien objects flying above the United
States or or the mother earth anything
you've ever heard of because I've not
ever had confirmation of it
well Sean if you're talking about aliens
and extraterrestrials I I can see a darn
thing about that as for the balloon uh
the administration actually provided a
briefing to me late this afternoon on
some of the details and there's a lot of
cleaning up to do we know there was the
balloon that transited the continental
United States we know that the bite
Administration now knew about this early
on and chose not to take it down before
it began its collection effort over the
United States the Chinese are squawking
saying it was a weather balloon we know
it wasn't a weather balloon and we know
that they had the capacity to control
the places that it went that is I've
also heard the by Administration say
well it was kind of just drifting that's
not fundamentally true they were able to
maneuver this with some specificity last
thing I've heard some even some
Republicans say well goodness they have
satellites
what could these balloons possibly do
these are different tools as the CIA
director I can assure you you want many
views many possibilities you want sound
you want imagery you want all of those
things and a low-flying balloon over our
military installations is a significant
not an insignificant event in the United
States of America let me I don't know
what's worth worth Mr secretary one the
fact that they are now claiming
something they didn't claim last week
that they knew when this spy balloon
took off uh then they allowed it to fly
over Alaskan airspace down the coast of
western Canada into Idaho over to
Montana over our ICBM missile sites into
Kansas State you know well and and
Missouri and Kentucky and the Carolinas
all the way out the East Coast
um I don't know if that's forced that
they waited that long or two that they
shot three objects out of the air using
our military but they have no idea what
they shot at or shot down can you
explain that
yeah equally troubling in different ways
you're right they flew over Kansas a
place where they could almost certainly
see Fort Leavenworth likely Fort Riley
Kansas as well some of our other
important military institutions sit
under the direct path that the Chinese
Communist Party intentionally flew their
balloon over while this Administration
sat there and just watched this happen
to your point about the other three
objects I don't know much more than has
been revealed publicly about what they
were I'm sure they had figured out at
some point that there weren't human
beings aboard these but we need answers
about what they were doing this is out
of pattern right we don't I don't know
of any other time that the United States
has shut down unidentified objects over
its own territory this is this is a big
deal
let me add one thing and say oh nothing
to see here they shot the three down
they don't know what they shot and they
said but we're pretty sure it's not from
China can you explain where that
rationale came from
I I can't other than if you connect that
up to what they've said about the fact
that they knew that this original
balloon actually did come from China
maybe they think because they weren't
able to detect that that they don't
think that's where this came from but I
don't know the answer to that Sean but
you know Sean we should back up just a
minute this is to your point in your
opening remarks this this is important
this is part of a collective action so
the balloons are a strand of a thread of
a cloth of the Chinese Communist Party
Espionage operations against the United
States and this Administration simply
refuses to take this threat seriously
instead is a passive and appeases the
Chinese Communist party in ways that
make no sense for the American people so
whether it's this balloon or as you said
with the virus or Tick Tock or all the
other tools that the Chinese are using
against the American people destroying
millions of our jobs this Administration
has declined to do anything that's going
to protect the American people we had
flipped the script for four years and
when the bite admissions Administration
came back in
they went right back to the engagement
model that hasn't served our country
well well one then has to ask the
question could it be because they have
such strong business ties with the Biden
family which I think America now needs
real serious answers to secretary Pompeo
as always thank you for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else